something really disgusting the guys
brought it to my attention because
richard has a house and uh richard has a
bathroom that
is his and his wife has her own bathroom
they've divided up the house
uh-huh richard refuses to clean the
bathroom oh
geez and it wait we're going to take a
tour right now
i'm going to show you this jason just
fill us in on some background about what
we're about to see in here howard i
can't stress this enough this is not
a bathroom that's tucked away in his
basement somewhere that only he uses
this is the main floor bathroom i
believe the only bathroom on that floor
so
it's the bathroom if you were ever to go
to his house that's the one that i would
assume the guests use richard let me see
what
jason's talking about so here we go
it's like a haunted house oh okay
i love how that sounds get closer on
that toilet
oh my god this [ __ ] on there this is the
toilet
dude dude there's [ __ ] on your toilet
all over the toilet i'm talking about
outside of the bowl crap
yeah cause you're crazy in dirt oh my
god
there's [ __ ] giant urine stains all
over the thing
oh there's a new trap dude dude i gotta
ask you why don't you just take the glue
trap and like
put down a new glue trap i mean there's
like a thousand dead bugs in there
all i think about howard is the poor
person who will inherit this house
after richard on this house it's a
rental
before a guy who launched this is
somebody's property
yeah so what it doesn't matter it's not
mine richard show them the sink
a lot of hair howard when we did the run
through the other day
not all the bugs were dead so some of
them were just kicking and twitching on
the
the glue trap while he's showing us
around this band wow notice
notice that the carpet he has in there
doesn't even fit it's like going up the
side of the wall because
you just have that halloween carpet in
there so bad go back to the sink for a
second
what is the rust i mean i just
everything is wrong
yeah what are the yeah there's not a bar
soap nearby but what is that
what are those two big stains like what
are those from
it's we had like soap holders there at
one time
and you gave up on soap exactly no
at some point you'd get disgusted you're
in right there
is anybody besides me curious like do
are we just buying the fact that this is
the only dirty room in the house
no it is gary we're real good about
keeping everywhere else cleaning
don't say yeah you're right uh now this
is just what we can see with our naked
eye
but there's still more disgusting when
you flip on the blacklight when you're
ready to see that flip on the black
light
make sure to show them underneath the
toilet hole
show them where you grab the toilet
paper richard
[Music]
so all those little areas that are lit
up is that where filth is
yes yes we look the black light finds
urine blood and semen
oh why is there pee on the top of the
toilet
that's where he came richard why is
there
richard the black light indicates lots
of urine
and fecal matter on the top of the
toilet how does it get up there
a lot of this was a mystery to me after
i turned on the blacklight too
does any of this scare you well yeah
once i turned the black light on i was
fairness you could see it without the
black light off yeah it was just as
gross before the dumb black light yeah
look at that he couldn't see any of that
howard that's definitely seeming
to think i want to see what's on that
sink
in this look at that there's splatter
everywhere
look at the stars at night stars
looks like the milky way the
constellations live in his sink
richard what is that the toilet paper
roll there is no toilet paper and yet
there's
all kinds of debris and germs and and
like piss
you know what i think might have
happened i might have put
a roll of toilet paper on there that was
soaked in urine or something
what makes checks out
oh there's something on the wall there
on the right what is this there was a
big glop
yeah i think i
see my feet against the wall look at
that semen stain it looks like a jackson
pollock painting like whereas
it's crazy it's like there's a big load
on the wall
just kind of just hanging there wow
i've never seen anything that gross like
i've seen some gross bathrooms
like at gas stations but that's worse